thrilled to have back here on the
program as i mentioned going to break i
believe the last time uh you were here
was for ford versus ferrari which was
just fantastic love that movie and now
long slow exhale will premiere
exclusively on spectrum
um
uh monday next week april 4th good to
see you josh lucas how are you sir
richard very happy to be back i really
like your show thank you very thank you
for saying that and i love all of your
work so i'll just call it a knock on
wood mutual admiration society right
here so this program is about a women's
basketball program you're playing an
athletic director
okay and
there are there it's a fascinating plot
involving uh a uh
big time spoiler potentially you know
the show's interesting man it like comes
from a so the woman pam bessie who's a
uh straight up older black female who's
one of the legendary uh showrunners in
hollywood one of the first who is a
black woman to do it right had two kids
who were driving towards the nfl draft
and i mean meaning that they were
spent their life working towards that
and when the duke lacrosse scandal
happened
she was so struck by it and so she said
what would happen if my boys in col you
know college i think they were in high
school at the time came home and they
both looked at me and said mom
we did not do this
and she said as a woman
what as a mom as someone who knows what
their careers i think are going to be in
terms of you know professional sports
um
what would i how would i respond and so
she really you know mused on it and took
it and turned it into what this show is
which is she shifted it to a women's
basketball team and the dynamics of it
really shifted but what she was struck
by and partly the reason why i'm here is
because one of the first people if you
remember who went down in the duke
lacrosse scandal was the athletic
director who had nothing to do with it
but you know that that charge you know
the exact charge you know and exactly
and you play again um an athletic
director in long slow exhale premiering
exclusively again on spectrum available
on demand free without ads i should
mention monday next week
april 4th uh 12 episode series three
episodes dropping each week for four
consecutive weeks josh lucas here on the
rich eisen show so this is essentially
born out of that
real life is absolutely brought out
story and that she you know obviously
needed to shift it for all sorts of
reasons and as the political landscape
and the metoo movement was happening and
all the different things that were
happening so the show is really
hitting on all sorts of
um
uh
areas right i mean everything from
championship basketball and the joy of
that and the the the responsibility and
issues that coaches have with young
women and then add a
sex scandal and add the pressures of a
national championship for a team that
comes kind of out of nowhere and
what that does to the school and it's
just it's got a a lot of a lot of things
a lot of moving parts and so uh starring
you josh lucas rose rollins who's
terrific frankie johnson who uh folks
know for many many great movies
absolutely and also tony gonzalez it is
that
tony
correct tony gonzalez
who uh hall of famer tony gonzalez was a
force to walk on the set and and does a
really nice job yeah
yeah he's you know it's too bad he
doesn't have a face for this sort of
thing
um
he's got a movie star facebook yeah yeah
you think
that's that'd be cool right i mean see
tony gonzalez walking on a set it was
cool pick his brain a little bit he was
he was if there was if there was a
someone who walked on with a lot of
extras it was one of the first scenes we
shot actually where everyone really
bubbled right yeah speaking of which i
really enjoyed your conversation with
sam farmer today terrific
i you know i have a little boy who i
told sam this my son is nine years old
and i genuinely will wake up in the
morning and he's already awake and he's
listening to
the seahawks locked on seahawks podcast
and he's talking to me and at six
o'clock in the morning as we drive to
school about what the
you know what draft picks or what draft
class is gonna happen with the
quarterbacks and all the different
things and and he
you know that conversation was so
interesting to me because he called me
like genuinely both excited almost in
tears when brady unretired and then
you know with what's going on with all
of this and and the seahawks and the
russell wilson thing has made him
i mean he's agitated that's what he's
about to say i was going to ask you josh
is like whose job is it is it your job
to explain to a nine-year-old why
russell wilson has to go or why he felt
he needed to go on i'm gonna tell you
what's interesting is that he's not he's
explaining it to me
i mean truly
this guy knows my little boy knows
you know why and and yet he was very
troubled by it and he was confused like
why did the coach say what he said
beforehand and i was like that's part of
the politics and that's the stuff he
wants to try and break down but you know
we truly listen to the the podcasts
about the seahawks and about the nfl and
your show uh driving to school um and he
he knows his stuff it's he says at this
point in his life he's gonna play
professional soccer
then retire in his late 20s and become a
general manager for the seahawks and
volunteer for the job so that they can
use the money they would save because
he's a volunteer because he's made so
much playing soccer yes that they can
use that for the salary okay so
i'm relieved to hear he's coming for
john schneider's job not mine that's
number one okay because it sounds like
you know he he would be ready to sit in
a seat like this one uh two he is aware
though that the money that the uh allen
family uh owns the seahawks right okay
okay so then you know
well it's like saving what a an ounce of
water out of the ocean you know what i
mean but he still thinks they'll be able
to use the money to get better players
i was like i don't know that the
administrative jobs are going to be able
to be able to be
you know worked into the salary cap and
he has an idea that that's what he's
going to do and plus you know what i i
mean we we have to connect because um
i'd love to talk to him um secondly if
he if he wants to ever call in and give
his opinions on the seahawks i love
having kids talk about this sort of
stuff because because not only do they
know but out of the mouth of babe you
know out of the mouths of babes comes
material that that you you won't expect
and then uh you know on top of it i mean
seahawks fans the day that russell
wilson got traded and bobby wagner gets
cut was truly one of the most difficult
days for any seahawks fan 9 19 29 90.
like it doesn't matter what age you are
it was shaking yeah it was it was you
know so
look uh
we
i mean i i i am developing not develop
i'm not pushing this development inside
of him but it's truly to see a kid who's
got this level of passion and i
understand why i mean truly the nfl
right now is the most
powerful force in entertainment on earth
and whatever they're doing and i spoke
to your guest sam about this this
morning in the in your waiting room
lovely waiting room thank you sir um
why and it's because whatever roger
goodell is doing in terms of the rubik's
cube of how he's moving it to push it
and and change it and shift it and sam
said something interesting he said you
know roger goodell's brilliance is
partly in the idea that they're never
saying oh well the thing we did on april
1st last year we're going to do again
this year right he said we're going to
we want to he said success is a problem
and that whatever is happening within
the nfl
dislike it love it whatever you want
it's the greatest entertainment maybe
we've seen in our lifetime well i can
personally attest that the the
commissioner when he first took the job
looked at everything that the nfl had
been doing and saying well how can we
improve it or change it or whatever um
that there there are no sacred cows
there there really are not and so the
you know the draft went from a two-day
weekend event in new york to a two-night
three-day event that now travels the
country that's just a perfect example of
how things have completely changed and
but it is the nfl is the greatest
narrative generating machine ever and
maybe even in entertainment where it is
the ultimate reality show exactly you
saw that with the super bowl right i
mean oh sure and and the stage i mean
that's that stadium is yeah it's insane
it's extraordinary it's truly one of the
most uh how how did your nine year old
take the the uh visual and audio assault
that that stadium and i shouldn't use
that word well but but it is it is it is
quite something that that oculus that
hangs from the ceiling of of sofi you
know is that was a big experience
something for him and i and it's
something that i can tell you i learned
from that day because i i know this
kid's passion for football is so extreme
father-son super bowl outing that i said
you know what i'm i'm gonna see if i can
pull some strings and get tickets and i
was not able to but i then decided all
right man you know bite the bullet and
pay for some tickets right wow
i'm the sort of guy
i'm the guy who doesn't do that in my
life i don't i i think any you know if i
i have a hard time spending money that i
think is frivolous right i really do and
and it's a maybe you could say a wink a
weakness or a strength of mine so but i
knew this kid's passion was so extreme
and i kept looking at tickets and i kept
going and i kept going and kept going
and so we went to the nfl experience on
saturday yeah and while we were at the
nfl experience i kept clicking on the
refresh button and suddenly these
tickets came up that were
frankly not crazy expensive right and i
i bought them and uh we
arrived the next morning
when the stadium opened we were waiting
outside when the stadium opened we went
in and it was
one of the best days of my life and i
tell you i walked away from the
experience with my son and driving home
and i thought this i want to do more of
this in my life i want not spend money
frivolously yes but like you work hard
and i want to give this kid and me and
him and the experience of enjoying our
life partly is what it is but it was
i mean look it was it was
beyond a beautiful experience for him
and i that he will remember for the rest
of his life and as will i josh lucas
here on the rich eisen show long slow
exhale available uh on exclusively it
will premiere on spectrum
uh starting monday of next week april
4th we have a couple of items from your
um you know your filmography and your
work um that uh also has generated a
couple of stories that we want to know
are true or false if you don't mind a
little celebrity true or false uh we
have some production value first go
ahead and hit it go ahead
celebrity true or false you can't handle
the truth there we go
that's just our way to set up true or
false celebrity true or false with josh
lucas okay first up sir um during
filming of sweet home alabama your
characters playing illegally landed on
peachtree lake and the production
company got a 300 ticket because of it
is that true or false
i think that's true
and the weird thing is is i know a girl
who i was maybe trying to date recently
who sent me a photograph of her new
boyfriend and her who he owns that plane
i was like out here
[Laughter]
i'm pretty sure it's true that it
illegally landed in the lake absolutely
and they're like screw it that we're
trying to get all these uh productions
here in georgia but
it's three hundred dollars that's when
disney can handle this right now i gotta
i gotta follow up so okay so you you you
you know a a young lady uh who you
reached out to um with certain
intentions and she's got she know her
current boyfriend she's not only
occupied but the guy owns the place we
we
when she lives somewhere else you know
the horrific world of internet dating
which i'm a part of these days um uh we
went back and forth and didn't ever able
to connect because she lived somewhere
else and then we just never did and but
we kept i liked her a lot and i kind of
lost track of her and all of a sudden
she sends me this photograph and says
listen i'm dating this guy i really like
but he he owns the plane from sends me a
photograph of the two of them standing
in front of the plane and i had mixed
feelings about it
i was like all right well
um yeah
damn wow
i don't know i don't even
yeah
wow
how does one get the plane from sweet
home alabama it was it's a cool plane it
is i bet that can land illegally on
pete's tree later
allegedly reportedly all right next one
uh true or false josh lucas you gained
43 pounds to play the role of don
haskins in gloria road is that true or
false haskins said to me almost on day
one look at that that's a bit just a bit
thicker than i am right now okay said to
me son they called me the fat man you
better start drinking beer
[Laughter]
i was in pretty decent
shape when we began i actually think
it's something that jerry bruckheimer
did not like about the way that i played
haskins because i think haskins would
have preferred i went a lot further and
they would have preferred i stayed you
know movie star handsome right uh so i
tried to cut it between the middle which
is kind of what the whole movie was
actually you know that movie is so inch
i
love that movie
uh but there is a rated hard r version
of the don haskins story and we made the
disney version and that's what don
haskins wanted he wanted the r no he
wanted he wanted the disney he wanted
the disney version and i respect that
entirely and i believe in that version
entirely it's a beautiful movie it's a
great movie wonderful but there but
his players
i don't think i've told this story ever
before and sure don't think i told it on
this this
show
okay one of the
hardest moments i would say in my whole
career
was after an early screening of sweet
home alabama where i had been a part of
a number of screenings where i'd gotten
standing ovations which i've never seen
for any before or since that i've been a
part of or any movie for that matter
but we went to el paso and we showed it
to the original team
and glory road you're talking about okay
yeah so we showed it to the original
players who are now you know older than
me and
and we all got into an elevator
afterwards and i expected that they were
all going to be all celebratory and
happy and frankly they were not
they looked at me and they shunned me at
first because they felt like i had not
captured
the vicious intensity of don haskins
and i think i made a choice with dawn
that that was kind of purposeful it's a
disney movie and to make it more
accessible that haskins
people know
in some ways out bob united bobby knight
and in terms of his toughness and
because of it his players love him in a
way that is like the greatest father
they've ever had or not ever
figured they sure had right and
they shifted gears though that's one
thing not to bring it around but they
shifted gears and they really i think
understood
partly haskins told them the
commercialization yeah it's a disney
movie sure right it's a disney movie
um
but there is you know there is a
there is a another version of that movie
and that story which is you know haskins
and the bobby knight you know
phase of his uh what he really was in
that way so i i throw that out there wow
so uh hopefully that elevator right you
get off on the second floor only i mean
like you're stuck by it i bet because i
had thought that they were all going to
be like it's amazing and they were
they've kind of they had to process it
they had to process it it seems like huh
well
haskins
they played
they played as you know about some of
these coaches
kind of out of fear of haskins
and
they they played at a level that he
pushed them you know and and that's what
i think the greatest coaches do
and he was young and a different phase
of his career than he was later um
he was hungrier and angrier and and
so yeah yeah
huh so um
did you last time what happened last
time
yeah josh last time you were here a
couple years ago you told us uh about
getting yelled at by pat riley
well again
what brockheimer does that i give so
much respect for to the way he makes
movies is he gives incredible resources
to
you know make it as entertaining as
possible but as authentic as possible so
my
coaches on that my technical advisors
who i had with me every day
were
tim floyd don haskins and pat riley and
they would rotate a little bit haskins
was the most lovely and gentle of the
group you know go drink tequila and talk
and have a nice time together
but pat riley and tim floyd were on me
in the way that a coach is on a player
and i had to sometimes say guys i'm
acting i'm not coaching
get off my back and it was a fascinating
experience and and and brockheimer
really pushes those bruckheimer's very
good friends with pat riley parallelly
gave me the best piece of advice in my
life get a physical every every year a
serious physical every year from the
time you're 30.
and you will be able to stay in
a healthier shape because of it i'm
about to go get mine
so uh but i have nothing but respect for
them in that experience um it was also
so interesting how different just like
directors and movies how different
coaches can be
with the same results right you were
talking about aryans and how erin's is
well i was talking sam about aaron's and
aaron's
what is going on between aryans and
brady right and he said possibly if the
aryans is kind of a laid-back dude but
then it's like yeah but he's talking
about cutting people out exactly so it's
a weird it's a weird it's really
interesting yeah coach player dynamic
yeah um third item on celebrity true or
false with you josh lucas is from the
same movie is it true don haskins made a
cameo as a gas station attendant yes he
absolutely does yeah and and if you
could find it there's got to be a photo
somewhere okay yeah i don't know if we
have the the rights to use that but
there's so he did play a gas station at
times did he ask to do that or did you
who asked him to do that
he was excited to do it definitely and
he was you know kind of
wonderfully mean during it
that's maybe where his players go oh we
know that gas station attendant uh all
right last one for you celebrity true or
false is the cars used in ford versus
ferrari were all real none of them were
cgi
oh absolutely true um there's almost
there's very little cgi in that movie uh
it was extraordinary to make because of
it
james mangle the director of that movie
does this extraordinary really
interesting thing
where even when the cars were off camera
he would still drive them by the shots
at speed in order to give the actors the
sense of the
sound and the intensity and the wind and
all of it and it really it was really
helpful
um
but yeah
and i do like the fact that you
mentioned tracy letts earlier because
he's one of my favorite people i ever
worked with i mean
incredible i don't know if you're
watching any of the winning time on hbo
right now i started it i like it it's a
heck of a lot of fun he's gonna show up
around what episode three or i think
it's episode three but as as the
would-be coach of jerry buss's would-be
first coach and
i just love everything that he's in he
was fantastic in ford versus ferrari it
does look like he when he was given that
ride as the executive when he was given
that ride i don't think he acted much i
don't think he knows like he wasn't he
was literally blown away by the speed
and the
and and and the the g the g4 whatever
you know
exactly like it definitely it's like
being in a fighter jet you know truly
you get i think five g's is what you'll
get up to in terms of when they're
really turning and all that and they had
this amazing machine called a biscuit
which is they took the actual cars and
they basically put another extraordinary
car that's attached to it that the
driver can be on top of the
in that case the old shelbys or they can
be on the side of it and they can have
the cameras there and everything but
they were driving at speed it was really
interesting in fact
uh
i just the other day was sitting up
where i live and i'm talking with my mom
and sister at a restaurant this guy
comes up to me and said hey you're josh
right we worked together on ford versus
ferrari and he was derrick hill his
father was
[Music]
one of the great race car drivers of all
time and won the f1 hill and he he was
the guy doing some of the driving in
that movie so they had this really cool
thing where they used a lot of the kids
of the actual drivers from that period
playing their parents yeah
authenticity
that movie was really one of my favorite
movies i so agree with you it was so
terrific and um i loved it you were
great in that everyone was great in it
and i think just to bring it all full
circle we do have the uh don haskins
there he is yeah look at him filling up
the car looking at him filling up look
at how much i look just like him
he was funny he was funnier than me
he was a great harassable wonderful dude
josh was it phil hill was the driver
nothing okay that bill hell that's
celebrity true or false for josh lucas
uh long slow exhale premiering
exclusively on spectrum again uh
starting next week on monday april 4th
any time and tell your son like if you
know if he wants to chime in on anything
he wants to chime in on any seahawks
like i love it when i look down at the
phone line and i see
someone take you up on that and i hear i
hear a kid's voice coming you know i i i
love it
i would ask if you if we do end up doing
this and i do think is disagree with him
he's really opinionated and i don't have
enough knowledge to back up of
disagreement with him oh no but he'll
teach him the ropes he'll get angry
about stuff that i'm like what are you
talking about like literally he's angry
at that okay the gm of the seahawks
right now for many different choices all
right so let's have him call in he's
also angry at russell wilson oh
definitely have him calling yes let's do
this very angry all right we'll give you
the special hotline number hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here